face the nation moderator Margaret
Brennan was at Joint Base Andrews this
morning when the three Americans arrived
she spoke with Vice President Mike Pence
thank you very much mr. vice president
what condition are these prisoners in
well they're receiving detailed medical
attention and have since they were
wheels up from North Korea but all of
them were in such good spirits to be
able to have an opportunity to visit
with them on the tarmac after the
president and the first lady brought
them out of the plane was deeply moving
to Karen and me and to have a few words
with them to hear their expressions of
support for the president their
gratitude to the country their gratitude
for the prayers of the American people
I'll remember the rest of my life we we
very much appreciate the the statements
and the efforts that Kim jong-un has
made so far to move us toward the path
to peace what is the release actually
signify to you though about Kim's
willingness to negotiate away his
nuclear arsenal when when negotiations
for denuclearization of North Korea
failed in the past the parties came
together promises were made and then
promises were broken but but the
promises weren't made by North Korea
until there were concessions and you
don't see this summit as a concession
well what I see is is when when the
South Koreans came with the request for
a meeting and said that that Kim jong-un
had said he was prepared to suspend
ballistic missile testing suspend
nuclear testing not object to American
military exercises and was requesting a
summit I was sitting next to the
president when virtually on the spot he
said yes we'll do it and it's because I
think the president senses an opening
that that may result in a historic
agreement as the president often says
we'll see but but it is accurate to say
that North Korea has taken steps so far
made commitments so far and making it
possible for these three Americans to
come home before there were any
concessions even offered by the United
States or our allies gives us hope this
may be different you've been speaking
with the Secretary of State who has been
on the ground in Pyongyang
in this meeting were there any new
concessions made any promises made about
what Kim will actually do with his
nuclear program what Kim jong-un has
said publicly and in discussions is that
he is prepared he is prepared to
negotiate to achieve complete
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
those words are important but we'll see
what they mean you spoke with the family
of otto warmbier the UVA student who
wasn't so fortunate and died shortly
after he was released from captivity
what did you say to his parents when we
spoke to him yesterday I simply let them
know that well while we we received this
news with joy that that otto was on all
of our hearts and their family was in
our prayers I mean that we we we got
Otto home last year but it wasn't soon
enough
there are also other families suffering
in Iran at least four American prisoners
are still being held there one of their
family members was at the White House
yesterday is the Trump administration
open to a prisoner swap I believe we are
always interested in opportunities to
bring Americans home but and that means
talking to Iran right now about doing
that well I think we sent a pretty
strong message to Iran this week when
the president made the decision to
withdraw from their Iran nuclear deal
and that's why the families are worried
that their family members may be held
hostage now to this diplomacy that's
been torn up we we felt it was important
to withdraw from this deeply flawed Iran
nuclear deal but now we're engaged
prisoners the possibility of a new deal
which may create opportunities for not
only addressing issues of Americans that
are detained in Iran
but also checking the extraordinary
malign influence and support for
terrorism that Iran continues to
propagate across the region and you
don't think that hurts your diplomacy
with North Korea President Trump
believes in peace through strength and
by withdrawing from the Iran nuclear
deal he's made it clear to the world
stage that we will not enter into a
deeply flawed agreement that does not
achieve the objectives that we stated as
the North Korean leadership looks at the
president's decision I think the message
they'll receive is he is going to hold
out for a deal that really achieves the
objective that has eluded the world for
more than a quarter of a century and
that is peace on the peninsula no more
nuclear weapons and and no more
threatening of our allies and neighbours
it was it really is very touching to see
them come home I think Paula said it
best when she said it's bittersweet it
was nice to see both vice president
Pence and the president acknowledged the
warmbier family holding on a very in
July yeah it's amazing the distance
we've traveled here remember the
president threatening kim jung-han to
now praising him the vice president
praised him and then you see the
Secretary of State with those big
glowing smiles as if he's a longtime US
ally the words the president used in
describing the North Korean dictator was
that he was very nice knowing who was
really excellent how he treated these
prisoners for the past several years
we're a long way from fire and fury
that's right there's still more to come
though